it's a cat and mouse game that favors
the protesters there are 600 gantries
over the M25 and please admit they can't
guard them all
right
since I was really worried about
distracting drivers it's an immense
worry but what else can we do to raise
the alarm
the just stop oil group wants the
government to block new fossil fuel
production because of climate change
police Chiefs say the protesters are
Reckless criminals who bring danger to
their officers motorists and themselves
they're Behavior criminal their behavior
is reckless their behavior is dangerous
and no protest activity should or can be
in a position where it puts lives at
risk their lives the lives of the public
on the road and of course my offices
the chief's warning came after one of
his motorbike officers was injured in a
crash during an earlier protest a just
stop oil supporter was questioned by
Mark Austin on Sky News about the
group's tactics your message is
certainly lost on the patient who didn't
get to hospital for her cancer treatment
appointment and your message is also
certainly lost on Tony bambry the man
who missed his father's funeral what is
the point of doing it like this
so it's very clear that the disruption
will end as soon as the government
issued this statement to stop new oil
and gas but we will have to continue
because at the moment I just do not know
what else we're going to do on the M25
in Kent Police Stopped a car and
arrested five suspects after seizing
climbing equipment locks and Banners
traffic's flowing for now but
campaigners say their protests or
actions as they call them aren't over
they say expect us every day and
anywhere
protesters were arrested others have
already appeared in court some are being
held in prison for a month and there's a
high court injunction Banning M25
disruption none of that appears to be a
deterrent
Martin brunt Sky News in Surrey